[MUSIC PLAYING]
Robots are what I do.
I like to build robots.
I like to program them.
To me, a robot is
something that's a machine,
and it somehow senses the world.
And then it computes, thinks
about what the sensors tell it,
and then it acts in the world.
For a number of years,
building robots [INAUDIBLE]
unstructured environments.
We've been building them
with three different levels
of control.
The primitive level, where the
motors and sensors operate.
A skills level, where
they have basic skills.
A behavior level, which
gives them behaviors
like going through
a mountain pass,
finding some dirt on the
floor to clean up, et cetera.
No.
You're not to do that.
Not appropriate.
No.
We are a mechanism.
If we are machines, then
in principle at least,
we should be able to
build machines out
of other stuff, which are
just as alive as we are.
So trying to make robots that
are safe to interact with,
so that ultimately doing stuff
with us and partnering with us,
is going to be important
in our old age.
We have to have more
robotics help and assistance.
We're not there yet,
but I think we're making
good progress towards it.